all right so yeah tell us how you got
into this at least
so you looked up host club tokyo and
then you applied for one in nicaragua
uh-huh and then you just walked in um
yeah basically is that easy well they
have an interview okay and they actually
pay you
to go to the interview can you believe
that is that new or is that like so has
it always been like um this is where the
you know difference in clubs come in so
for example if you go to a you know very
well-known club in
kabukicho like
you know if you know that's like one of
the [ __ ] most prestigious i know the
name yeah yeah so they're not gonna pay
you to go there you know you're gonna go
there you're gonna do the interview and
they're gonna tell you to [ __ ] off like
90 of the time yeah yeah but smaller
clubs and you know [ __ ] nowhere like
ikebukuro kind of
they are lacking staff so they need more
hosts to actually fill the you know
place right um so they actually pay
people to take the interviews because
they can afford it wait so they pay you
even if you don't get in yeah exactly
they pay you for your time bro wow so
actually the first oh yeah so is the
host industry that big that we have like
a shortage of like employees in the host
industry um i mean there is a shitload
of host clubs in just in tokyo yeah so i
mean i guess the demand is there yeah
wow okay i guess i guess it's not really
like apparent maybe yeah just look at it
from a surface of like just how much in
demand it is i think back in the day at
least for girls bars i i've read that
they would literally just like hire
tourists
really no they weren't oh they're not
allowed to obviously yeah of course like
they would hire foreign girls for girls
bars that would work tourist visas they
would just you could just like girls
would just walk into bars
i could believe that yeah i want to work
here yeah okay sure wow i met a girl
like that the other day actually
dude
near a girls bar next to my house um
that i always go to just to check out
like who's new and stuff
there was this russian girl
who's here for like exchange yeah you
know she's only here for like four yeah
yeah that's supposed to be working
yeah exactly
yeah exactly no it's nothing legal but
she's still there i'm sure that's not
the dodgiest thing you've seen but we'll
get into yeah we'll we'll get into some
of the other stories later if you join
this you know you get paid for the
interview yeah so i hope two places and
then at that time i was thinking like
how about i hop like 50 places and not
join any of them
because because when you said that they
would pay you and not even join i'm just
like i'm just like that's there's an
idea exactly what if i just apply to
jobs and not join how does this
interview process go then do they you
just make make you drink like so you go
you fill in like a basic sheet that's
kind of the employment thing your name
your address and whatnot um and then
they ask you questions just to chat with
you you know have you ever done this
before am i good at socializing can you
handle drinks how does that not work
before i can't actually yeah
i just you know watch league of legends
but yeah um i was gonna
originally do like a hopping thing just
to collect like and they pay a lot they
pay like 4 000 somewhat to pay six
thousand so it's four justices yeah yeah
yeah just to go to an interview which
finishes like an hour bro i know right
crazy so
so how many hours is that on the
pizzeria
it's like don't even mind like five six
hours yeah that's like
six hours like a single interview yeah
that place was not about money it's
about like the friends we made along the
way
[Laughter]
how much longer do we have to have them
on the show
just getting smashed by myself
anyway yeah so so you decided to join
the ikebukuro one oh yeah so after two
interviews i decided you know what i
kind of like this place
um so it was a really interesting one
because until that point they never
really made me sit with an actual
customer all right but for the ikebukuro
place that i went to um it was called
asset um that place literally made me
sit down with a customer and just drink
with them straight up all right so it
wasn't even like it was like trial by
fire it was just around an actual
customer that was there yeah exactly
exactly but it was like one of the close
you know um customers of one of like the
members there right you know he the
chacho asked him like is it okay if we
have like this random ass guy just chat
with her for a bit just to see if he's
capable yeah and you know she said [ __ ]
yeah so i sat down drank [ __ ] bigger
bombs with her
[ __ ] love was that her choice
my choice bro oh my god
of course you of course you're 18 at the
time
[Music]
it's got like some substance in it
that's like
it's like i think it's actually in the
[ __ ] and the alcohol yeah actually
something like that yeah it's awful for
your heart yeah i yeah i'm not surprised
bro
i think i i served it in the the gay bar
video i did yeah
it's a green it's like a green one yeah
a red bull at the bottom then it's just
like red bull with cochlear juice
on the bottom and then it sounds [ __ ]
and then it's the the 40 spirit on top
and like they're not supposed to mix
yeah so the idea is that it's like this
presentation that's like fancy and stuff
bloody hell it's [ __ ] i think you can i
think you pull someone out of a coma
with them yeah genuinely like just like
just dude you should let's just christen
people with that the [ __ ] baby will
start
oh the babe will stop floating
away
sorry go ahead yeah yeah so you sat down
with this lady oh yeah just like trying
to try it out yeah so that was your
first time yeah first time ever did you
kill it did you get one was it awkward
yeah no not at all man what are you
drinking with her um you know like why
did you come here well i'm trying it out
i'm a student blah blah blah oh she was
just like she was interviewing you she
maybe she was the real person that was
the real interviewer this is like some
undercover boss
i'm actually the owner
of the interview the thing is i'll get
into this a bit more later but like you
know
in like the traditional way of doing
hostile you're supposed to have the
other person talk the most yeah and
that's with any sales tactic right if
you come out of an interview in general
talking more than the other person that
means you have to do the selling right
if you make the other person talk more
that means you know they're trying to do
something to impress you or they're just
having a good time that they just want
to talk more
but
in this case you were just asking me
questions like where are you from why
did you have a [ __ ] beard how are you
18 holy [ __ ] 35 you know stuff like that
yeah
multiple stuff and like the more i
answer stuff it intrigued her more to
ask more questions so you know at the
end she said you know i want to see this
guy again you know [ __ ] hire him the
guy was like let's go start tomorrow
right right i can make it sound so
simple just uh just ask questions yeah i
mean you guys probably not but you could
become a hostel tomorrow bro why me
because you speak japanese
it doesn't mean i'm good at socializing
not that i have any plans to be a host
sorry guys i'm not going to well we have
a plan don't you think yeah i want to do
like a version two of it what do you
mean the host club video the host video
all right all right yeah did you go chat
now it's like show you around exactly
yeah it's very good in the video yeah
bro i want to take you to you know my
homie's place
show you around when jan says homie's
place it's like i just think you're like
the most sketch [ __ ] yes
i don't know why i have like my my
preconceptions of host clubs and and
whatnot just because from filming my
video where i went to host club yeah and
i got to see everything there you know
and obviously we cut a lot of stuff that
i couldn't show but yeah you know one
misconception i had about host clubs is
that i thought you had to be like
[ __ ] like literally looking like a
rock star like sexy as [ __ ]
it's like you literally just have to
have a like a gimmick right almost and
this guy's gimmick was that he was an
[ __ ]
that was like his character right mainly
was that yeah so i think like was what
was it and who's kind of
who's you know he was a bit larger yeah
yeah yeah but he was just big
oh he calls himself a pig and also i am
very grateful they let me film i mean
they they really did like give me like
all access and like it's pretty tough to
get permission
you know they're really nice about it
like you have to like hook them up and
stuff no
no i didn't do anything did we no listen
no nothing we literally just shouted out
his youtube i think that was it yeah it
was it was one of the situations where
i didn't really know what was going on i
don't think any of us really knew what
was happening right we just kind of got
dragged in and we were doing it and i
didn't know if i was going to pay for
stuff yeah yeah yeah
but like you know he was i from what i
was gathering like he he was being rude
like it was partially a character but i
think there was partially some of it
that might have been how he has to stem
from somewhere right you know i he was
trying to be funny yeah as well like he
was trying to crack jokes yeah at my
expense which i didn't mind i you know i
can i can take that yeah i'm not uh
yeah i don't know i i you know i mean
maybe you know sometimes when you bring
cameras into a place like that sometimes
people will feel like they want to you
know one-off show off yeah yeah do i
seem like that to you right now no no no
no
i know that you [ __ ] up
but uh you're more of an [ __ ]
off-camera yeah
is not the case
that is not the case